[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir on refait le match on
va revenir largement sur le débat
d'entre deux tours diar soir emmanuel
macron à l'offensive marine le pen en
défense qui a gagné ce duel suivi par
plus de 15 millions de français on passe
au scanner ce soit les mots les regards
les postures mais aussi les propositions
et les réactions bien sûr en décryptage
sur ce plateau dans un enfant avec nos
invités notre grand témoin ce soir a
consacré toute sa vie à l'europe qu'il a
défendu à bruxelles notamment comme
commissaire européen qui le font
aujourd'hui à la tête de l'institut
jacques delors cette europe percuté
aujourd'hui de plein fouet par la guerre
en ukraine à l'heure où vladimir poutine
revendique la prise de marioupol on a
plein de questions à poser à pascal lamy
notre invité ce soir voilà donc pour le
menu attaques sévères n'oubliez pas on y
va
[Musique]
on
j'ai eu face à moi un emmanuel macron
égal à lui même
très méprisant très arrogant
y compris dans sa posture dans le débat
ça a été très claire elle a confondu le
terrorisme la sécurité l'immigration
l'islam et l'islamisme en permanence
voilà donc deux manières bien
différentes de percevoir les choses
bonsoir à tous les candidats sont de
retour sur le terrain emmanuel macron en
seine saint denis en terrain plutôt
hostile on a voté là bas jean luc
mélenchon et puis marine le pen dans la
somme en terrain conquis en terrain
conquis puisque ce soir à l'est en
meeting dans le pas-de-calais 24 heures
après ce grand rite électorale très
suivis par les français on va refaire le
match avec vos bertrand perrier bonsoir
bonsoir merci infiniment d'être là vous
êtes avocat et grand spécialiste de
l'art oratoire bonsoir emily's apathie
qui sort et bienvenue sur ce plateau
communicante politique et conseil en
image l'image était évidemment au coeur
de ce débat richard vers les bienvenus
correspondant parisien du quotidien
suisse le temps et visage familier de
cette émission vous êtes chroniqueurs et
puis raphaël legendre bonsoir à vous
pour les décryptages économique
journaliste écho à l'opinion on commence
donc par la forme depuis hier soir vous
le savez le procès en arrogance a été
largement réactiver le procès en
arrogance d' emmanuel macron pour ses
opposants et bien voilà posture du
président candidat qui en dit long sur
plombante condescendante tu peux le dire
at on pu lire dans les dents les
commentaires avant de vous entendre on
va revoir quelques séquences de ce body
language à la fois du président candidat
mais aussi de sa concurrente du
rassemblement national regarder ces
compilées par les os
emmanuel macron étaient pourtant
prévenus surtout ne pas paraître
arrogant mais ses efforts n'ont pas
suffi sur les réseaux sociaux les
internautes trahit sa posture en cause
sa gestuelle ce sont les contrer l'index
accusateurs
à chaque fois c'est à côté sourire
narquois que vous voulez faire de la
france le premier pays au monde qui
interdirait le voile sur la voie
publique vous le doigt pointé sur la
tempe comme pour laisser entendre que la
mesure de son adversaire et
déraisonnable au coeur des critiques
aussi le ton et une certaine suffisance
il arrêter de tout confondre chez makro
ne me donnez pas de leçons
parce qu'il faut quand même pas non plus
madame le pen ou sais mais je tiens à
redire et a dit mais emmanuel macron a
su faire jouer son sens de la formule
dans un vocabulaire parfois suranné mais
que vous ayez l'autre quid ans de dire
qu'on est des grands groupes en
expliquant que donc le marché européen
finito on peut on peut décider de
ripoliner tout seul la façade gérard
majax ce soir madame le pen a un peu
perdu au début marine le pen fait un
faux départ
ils se montrent hésitantes notamment
avec les chiffres tant que la
l'inflation est supérieure d'un point à
la croissance ce qui est le cas
évidemment actuellement avant oui oui
oui c'est le cas actuellement oui oui
dans les chiffres constatés ou prévus
oui oui dans les chiffres prévus et dans
les chiffres du deuxième trimestre aussi
d'admettre padacke résiliente elle
réussit tout de même à se refaire à
coups de punchlines
en aucun cas mais vous vous êtes un peu
klimato hypocrite le mozart de la
finance c'est comme ça que on vous avait
présenté je dis pas que vous étiez
présenté mais on vous avait présenté un
bilan économique qui est très mauvais
marine le pen n'a sans doute pas gagné
ce débat mais est la différence d'il ya
cinq ans elle ne s'est pas ridiculiser
alors on va commencer par vaux bertrand
perrier puisque c'est le grand
spécialiste emmanuel macron d'abord
cette position-là affalé la moue
dubitative qu'on a vu sur tous les plans
d' écoute qu'est ce qu'elle vous a
inspiré qu'est ce qu'elle dit du
président candidat il dit qu'ils les
jugent qu'il est à la fois partie mais
aussi juge et qu'il fait passer à marine
le pen une sorte d'examen et que
finalement il va retourner la situation
où ils devraient justifier du bilan qui
est le sien et qu'il va lui demander à
elle de justifier ces votes ces chiffres
ces financements et donc il a passé la
soirée à s'ériger en juge a donné des
bons points des mauvais points vous avez
raison là dessus là dessus les chiffres
ne sont pas bons et ce body dingue je
disais tout ça donnait la leçon général
donnait la leçon la corse en
surplomb avec un regard un peu goguenard
parfois approbateurs parfois en frise et
parfois parfois complètement infligé
mais toujours dans une posture de
jugement et donc il était aussi le juge
de son propre débat aller chercher aussi
le regarder des journalistes comme si sa
concurrente n'était pas au fond à la
hauteur comme si l'alter ego était
plutôt du côté des des commentateurs que
depuis l'été de la candidature alors il
y avait la question du regard aussi
puisque souvent ils ne la regardait même
pas soit ils regardaient en effet les
journalistes soit ils regardaient même
ses notes ce qui est objectivement assez
discourtois il y avait la question de la
posture physique à la fin il était
vraiment très au fond de son fauteuil un
peu comme l'était valéry giscard
d'estaing dans les années soixante dix
mais à l'époque ça s'expliquer
aujourd'hui maintenant on a une posture
beaucoup plus en avant que marine le pen
a conservé pendant tout tout le débat
est donc c'est vrai qu'il y avait eu un
relâchement à la fin après il ya les
expressions que vous avez mises en avant
sur ces mots un peu un peu suranné
gérard majax à c'est un peu boomer
gérard majax mais après tout pourquoi
pas mais c'est vrai que son body
language signé le fait qu' il avait
voulu inverser la logique de ce débat
qui aurait voulu qu'il soit contraint de
se justifier et en réalité il a inversé
les choses et il lui a demandé à elle
dans ce jus donc c'était presque voulu à
vous entendre
quelque chose de naturel qui transpire
là dedans c'est évidemment tout à fait
travailler et cette inversion de
perspectives me paraît tout à fait prévu
on a su poser la question parce qu'après
coup évidemment c'est l écueil dans
lequel il devait pas tomber l'arrogance
on lui a toujours reproché ça et c'est
vrai que là c'était une belle
démonstration en tout cas la première
partie parce qu'après il s'est corrigé
il est rentré vraiment dans le débat il
s'est libéré de sa de cette espèce des
coudes sur jouer ou parle toujours
finalement voilà déroule sa jeu elle a
en effet jeté dans le piège mais je ne
suis pas plus moi je me suis posé la
question est-ce que c'était pas fait
exprès mais un point c'est à dire de
parler à son électorat parce que
finalement c'est un débat ils ont pas
tellement élargi l'idée c'est quand même
d'aller chercher ces voix de gauche qui
sont allés chez jean luc mélenchon pas
forcément que des mélenchonistes des
écolos des gauches ils sont pas allés
tellement chercher ça et finalement ils
ont parlé chacun à leur électorat
peut-être cette mise en scène était
assez consciente et assez volontaire
pour dire moi je suis au dessus de la
masse je suis au dessus de marine le pen
je suis au dessus quelle que soit la
prestation gaffes et qui sera toujours
jugée meilleure que 2010 est puisqu'elle
avait vraiment raté son débat est
quelque part et va parler elle va
dérouler je vais de ci de là comme
disait bertrand corriger un petit peu
quand c'est mal fait par contre moi il
me semble que ça a été une erreur parce
que ça a été un très mauvais démarrage
pour tout le monde pour l'impression
globale et pour l'image qui va se
traîner encore qu'il a toujours et qui
va se traîner et qui l'éloignent
beaucoup des français et un jour ça va
quoi qu'on en dise cette question de la
démocratie de la représentativité de la
proximité avec les français mais quand
il s'est débarrassé de ça il a été très
bon et on retrouvait un petit peu ce
candidat de 2010 est plus dans les
landes dans un projet qui n'était pas
très défini c'est plutôt la continuité
son projet mais quand il s'est libéré de
sa il était plus authentique
quelque-part d'abandonner à force cette
idée qu'on peut avoir un petit sourire
narquois travail et préméditée presque
avant peut-être de s'en libérer et
marine le pen réservé mais comment vous
l'avez trouvé sur la forme on
l'attendait à l'offensive elle était
plutôt en retrait je crois qu'elle a
joué complètement défensif alors moi je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec les
commentateurs français qui ont dit que
ma qu'on lui avait été offensif je les
trouvais assez défensif aussi j'ai pas
ce qu'il a il a vraiment tout fait comme
le disait bertrand à l'instant pour
qu'elle ne l'attaquent pas sur son bilan
et il a réussi puisqu'en fait il là il
l'a prise à chaque fois sur son
programme moi j'ai trouvé que la
difficulté avec marine le pen si je
prends je voulais prendre une métaphore
sportive c'est qu'elle tient pas la
distance c'est à dire que sur la
totalité de l'émission il ya trop de
moments où elle est mise en difficulté
mais quand elle arrive à monter son
niveau là il était plutôt bonne elle
parlé clairement elle parlait comme les
gens et c'était son objectif elle disait
des choses qui étaient plus simples à
comprendre qu'ils emmanuel macron elle
avait quelques bonnes formules l'a dit
qu'elle a lavé l'affront de l'elysée
c'est qu'elle n'arrivait pas dire cette
distance 3 heures c'est long et on sait
que lui sur la distance il est bon
raphaël legendre stratégie un peu à
fronts renversés finale lentement c'est
exactement ça avec chacun son objectif
marie le pen s'était effectivement elle
avait tout à gagner à ce débat marine le
pen elle devait laver l'affront de 2017
son humiliation comme elle
même qualifiée mais du coup elle a été
extrêmement sûre quand même moi je
trouve sur la défensive elle ou il une
fébrilité mais dès les premières
secondes du débat en réalité quand elle
démarre son argumentation pendant même
le générique de début ça montre une
certaine fragilité qu'il n'a pas quittée
finalement tout du long de l'émission en
surjouant la candidate posé plus calme
elle a hâté finalement beaucoup
d'occasions de se défendre aussi parce
qu'en face d'elle elle avait al'inverse
un candidat que moi j'ai trouvé assez
offensif qui effectivement est assez
habilement à renverser la charge de la
preuve c'était lui l'homme du passif
normalement c'est le président sortant
c'est son quinquennat
il a complètement retourné la situation
en attaquant le bilan de la députée
marine le pen à la fois sur son
absentéisme et sur toutes les mesures de
soutien aux ménages et aux entreprises
créées
on va regarder les éléments sur sur le
fond mais je voudrais vous entendre
encore battre en perrier sur ce maudit
la gauche cette fois-ci de marine le pen
vous a préparé quelques photos alors
elle a souvent les mains jointes on va
la regarder et puis elle a aussi parfois
ses mains croisées avec aussi ce geste
elle revêt elle remet ses cheveux très
régulièrement ou alors elles réajuste
aussi beaucoup la veste est ce que c'est
une malle à sueur ans non c'était juste
assez naturel pour une femme qui a des
cheveux j'aimerais bien pouvoir faire là
bas
mais en fait ce qui m'a frappé dans le
body language de marine le pen c'est
qu'elle a abandonné ce faux sourire
qu'elle avait arboré en 2017 qui cadrait
absolument pas avec la solennité d'un
débat présidentiel vous souvenez ça va
donner lieu d'ailleurs au
mick sûr ils sont dans les campagnes sur
les réseaux sociaux on avait
l'impression qu'elle prenait ça à la
légère et là on n'a pas eu ça du tout on
a eu un bon feeling très maîtrisée on
sait d'ailleurs même qu'elle a changé de
veste parce qu'elle trouvait à la
dernière minute que ça ne cadrait pas
avec le décor donc elle était attentive
à tout ça je voudrais dire une chose sur
le décor j'ai trouvé étonnant que le
fond de ce débat pour la plupart du
temps soit le palais de l'elysée il se
trouve que parmi les candidats il y en a
un qu'il occupe et l'autre qui ne
l'occupent à
papier coulisses dans la presse ce matin
disent bien qu'elle n'était pas très
content je trouve qu inconsciemment et
la raison en effet de s'offusquer de ce
symbole qui est favorise un peu son
concurrent mais c'est vrai dans son body
language elle a été plus sobre et mieux
venu que en 2017 alors sur le fond à
présent on y va les deux candidats se
sont affrontés sur l'économie bien sûr à
commencer par le pouvoir d'achat mais
peut-on dire pour autant que leur vision
de l'économie est diamétralement opposée
éléments de réponse avec les mômes eric
pour améliorer le pouvoir d'achat des
français les deux candidats misent
d'abord sur le travail avec emmanuel
macron une entreprise ne pourra plus
verser de dividende aux actionnaires
sans accorder une prime défiscalisé à
ses salariés marine le pen elle préfère
inciter les employeurs à augmenter les
salaires en échange elle supprimera les
cotisations patronales liés à ces
hausses
on est sur des logiques
similaires c'est à dire baisser les
cotisations sociales employeurs en
espérant obtenir ainsi des hausses de
salaires ou des hausses de primes avec
le risque que les entreprises aient un
effet d'aubaine pour des augmentations
qu'elle aurait fait de toute façon et
avec le risque ça nuit au financement de
la sécurité sociale
deux logiques différentes s'affrontent
pour aider les français face à la hausse
des prix dans les rayons des
supermarchés marine le pen veut
supprimer la tva sur 100 produits de
première nécessité emmanuel macron lui
préfère accorder un chèque alimentaire
aux contours encore flous mais qui
ciblerait uniquement les français qui en
ont le plus besoin on a deux mesures qui
sont radicalement différentes à la
baisse de la tva sur les produits de
première nécessité est une mesure peu
efficace parce que sensible pas les plus
pauvres est qu une partie serait perdue
dans l'augmentation des marges de
communautés commerçants quant au chèque
alimentation c'est une mesure qu'ils ont
transitoire compliqué alors qu'ils
seraient quand même beaucoup plus simple
d'augmenter les mines les minima sociaux
face à la flambée des prix du gaz de
l'électricité et du pétrole emmanuel
macron veut prolonger le bouclier
tarifaire qui l'a mise en place marine
le pen elle propose de faire passer la
tva de 20 à 5 5% sur les carburants le
fioul le gaz et l'électricité la baisse
de la tva sur les produits énergétiques
est une très mauvaise mesure parce qu'il
elle va en sens inverse de notre
engagement de réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre le bouclier
tarifaire c'est une mesure acceptable à
condition que ce soit une mesure tout à
fait temporaire si on veut respecter nos
engagements dans le cadre de l'accord de
mars enfin le gendre décryptage de henri
sterdyniak sur l'aspect pouvoir d'achat
sur les visions de l'économie des deux
candidats et sont si différentes que ça
oui d'abord là deux modèles totalement
opposées vous avez macron l'européen
contre marine le pen la souris ni ça ça
entraîne de cela découle des modèles
totalement différent sur le point précis
du pouvoir d'achat vous avez
effectivement de vision lune qui passe
pas des baisses de fiscalité général
c'est le côté marine le pen avec tous
les problèmes que ça pose derrière ça a
été beaucoup décrypter avant ce débat
des problèmes au niveau européen la tva
et le sérum est encadré par une
directive européenne donc il y aurait
déjà un premier front face à la
commission et aux autres et amendes si
elle souhaitait l'appliquer et également
au niveau constitutionnel au niveau
français sur différentes mesures mais
surtout la grande différence c'est que
ces baisses de tva concerne absolument
tout le monde y compris comme l'a
souligné emmanuel macron sur le plateau
les plus aisés qui n'en n'ont pas
forcément besoin al'inverse des mesures
ciblées effectivement comme le chèque
inflation ou le chèque alimentaire qu'il
souhaite mettre en place mais ils
oublient aussi qu'il a quand même bloqué
les prix et cela pose également
il ya quand même beaucoup redoutent
aussi longs efforts mais aussi des
terrains communs entre les deux mais
marine le pen n'a pas su parce qu'elle
n'est pas assez solide sur ses
fondamentaux économiques a n'a jamais
été confortable dans cette matière elle
n'a pas su rebondir pour attaquer le moi
j'ai la musique c'était quand même un
match nul sur ce pouvoir d'achat qui
était quand même le thème de
prédilection c'était le thème de
campagne de marine le pen elle a eu du
nez parce que c'était quand même un
thème porteur mais là au bout du bout de
la chaîne ça a bien fonctionné hier bien
dans toute sa campagne a porté sa
campagne est bien partie contrôlant
durant le débat très clair mais lui a
permis d'enlever tout ce qui était
immigration ajoutée et ça il faudrait
revenir mais en effet l on n'a pas
profité là pendant ce débat mais elle
avait des mesures simplistes elle
explique pas bien elle sait pas très
bien les expliquer les détails et mais
en face on avait un emmanuel macron très
techno il a été beaucoup dans le détail
s'était pas beaucoup plus audible donc
finalement ça sa taxe le côté tva c'est
très simple à comprendre
on comprend on a l'impression que tout
de suite on va voir l'addition pour
notre porte-monnaie j'ai l'impression
qu'ils avaient un match nul que personne
n'a réussi vraiment lassant arrière sur
ce sujet là oui ce qui était intéressant
c'était effectivement comme le dit
émilie il y avait un candidat très
analytique et une candidate qui était
très dans le concret il dit dans la
vraie vie ça se passe comme ça il y
avait un peu comme le froid le candidat
du réel le candidat du rpt sentiers et
et elle elle lui c'est vrai cite
l'exemple du 4 on n'est pas comme ça et
elle elle cite l'exemple les français
les uns fait
de dire moi je suis allez rencontrer des
gens j'ai rencontré dans l'argent elle
avait une bonne jeune line là dessus
qu'ils étaient il faut rendre l'argent
aux français elle l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises et lui a essayé de poursuivre
le procès en incompétence sur la
question vous ne maîtrisez pas les
salaires et donc on est un peu en effet
sur deux logiques rhétorique aussi le
concret de son côté est quelque chose de
plus crédible chiffrées du côté des
maillots la grèce qui était extrêmement
frappant richard wehrli dans l'ensemble
du débat quelles que soient les thèmes
c'est finalement qu'on était dans la
distribution généralisée des de soutien
de chefs d'incitation et d'argent public
dépensées il a fallu un ancien premier
ministre ce matin pour rappeler qu'il y
avait une grande absente dans ce débat
écouter on a très peu parlé des
questions d'équilibré budgétaire on a
très peu parlé en effet les questions de
financement de notre économie de
financement de l'état
jeune je n'en suis pas surpris je n'en
suis pas surpris parce que pendant les
périodes de campagne électorale
je constate que très souvent et c'est
pas propre à cette campagne électorale
on essaie d'éviter de parler des choses
qui fâchent
bon c'est comme ça on parle de sujets
dont on aimerait sur lequel on aimerait
voir des avancées et on essaie de ne pas
parler des choses qui fâchent et les
choses qui fâchent c'est le risque que
notre pays se trouve dans une situation
budgétaire
plus compliqué un jour il a raison
d'avertir attention à la douche phrase
on on rase gratis un peu dans cette
campagne c'est sûr que vu sous l'angle
européen en tout cas européens du nord
vu du côté de pays frugaux c'est juste
ahurissant
et là la chose étonnante c'est qu'en
fait c'est marine le pen qui au qui a
poussé l'estocade sur les 600 milliards
de dettes et elle s'est arrêtée elle
aurait pu aller plus loin et
éventuellement sur ce terrain mais elle
sait que sur ce terrain c'est difficile
pour elle parce qu'elle elle propose de
distribuer aussi mais en clair oui la
dette publique en france n'est pas un
sujet présidentielle et ça c'est
quasiment inédit au niveau européen en
tout cas je le disais de la part de pays
européens du nord et notamment vu d'alma
ni la deuxième chose moi qui m'a frappé
c'est que quand même il a marqué un vrai
point ce petit moment de doute où il
rappelle que c'est les entreprises
c'est-à-dire les patrons qui fixe les
salaires et non pas le candidat à la
présidentielle et là on sent un petit
moment de flottement on se demande même
si elle a elle a vraiment réalisé la
ferme marine le pen et ce petit moment
de flottement il est redoutable parce
qu'on se dit finalement elle
comprendrait pas la logique à l'armada
flottement qu'on a qu'on a vécu
plusieurs fois perdu un peu dans ses
fiches à se tromper entre l'inflation la
croissance un tout petit point de fact
checking comme on dit en bon français
sur les 600 milliards de dettes parce
que emmanuel macron dit c'est faux c'est
pas le cas on m'a averti que c'est dans
le sujet alors on attend
et puis vous reviendrez juste après je
me rends dans la suite moi je pense que
le sujet de la dette évidemment qu'il
est pas là on a eu le coc vide là
maintenant la crise ukrainienne on a
déboursé 100 milliards par ci 30
milliards par la plan de relance plan
france de fluence france relance 2030
c'est pas le sujet on sait très bien
maintenant qu'on peut qu'on a le droit
de débloquer le déficit budgétaire
européen on a débloqué pendant la crise
pendant la crise qu vis de l'allemagne a
dit ok on a fêté le débat très français
et parce qu'il ya d'autres pays et non
un lieu aussi le co vident et où il a
été compris en france et on en est quand
même à plusieurs centaines de milliards
d'euros qui ont été dépensés pour le
quoi qu'il en coûte le fonds de
solidarité le soutien aux entreprises de
soutien au chômage partiel on sait que
c'est possible les retraites on sait que
ça peut être l équilibre bien sûr qu'il
va falloir payer cette dette mais c'est
pas le sujet à l'heure actuelle les
français sont pas du tout prêts à
entendre ça mais c'est un problème
très important je sais que ces questions
vous tiennent à coeur richard va revoir
cet extrait c'est à tout ou rien c'est
pas on prend tout et on ne dit rien ou
alors on prend rien je souhaite rester
dans l'union européenne je souhaite
profondément la faire modifier pour
effectivement faire émerger une alliance
européenne des nations pourquoi parce
que d'abord il ya toute une série de
politiques de l'union européenne avait
claqué avec lesquels je suis en
désaccord on peut décider de ripoliner
tout seul la façade mais enfin c'est pas
prendre et c'est une copropriété donc à
un moment donné dans une copropriété
vous pouvez pas dit du jour au lendemain
ça s'appelle plus la copropriété ça
s'appelle comme j'ai décidé parce que je
m'appelle madame le pen eh bien j'ai
beaucoup plus ambitieux vous mais madame
le pen moi j'ai une ambition je la porte
je fais dans le respect des autres et
j'ai fait avancer les choses mais je ne
ment pas sur la marchandise
vous mentez sur la marche là il ya un
moment important du débat parce que
d'abord celui qui se fait le mieux
comprendre c'est très clairement et
manuellement oui il ya 2 il ya deux
points importants le premier c'est que
marine le pen dit jeu et dans l'union
européenne vous ne pouvez pas bio je
vous êtes obligés quand même de dix ans
nous un moment donné et de compter les
pays qui sont avec vous et la deuxième
difficulté c'est que il a un peu tort
quand il dit que c'est une copropriété
est ce que tous les copropriétaires ne
sont pas égaux il est évident que si
deux copropriétaires notamment la france
et l'allemagne voire l'italie avance
ensemble ça a quand même du poids dans
la maison sauf qu elle veut se fâcher
avec l'allemagne donc elle se fâche avec
le principal copropriétaires donc de ce
point de vue il a raison moi je trouve
quand même que dans ce que vous dites si
on a dit jeu pendant la crise qu'ovide
encore une fois en europe certains ont
dit je je prends des masques par si je
prends des choses par là et je moi je
défends pas du tout la thèse de marine
le pen mais c'est entendable dans la
mesure où on peut imaginer que certains
et son électorat évidemment ait envie de
bouger des choses dans l'union
européenne emmanuel macron il a très
clairement dit apporter des changements
sur les vaccins sur la dette justement
sur ce plan d'investissements énormes
que l'europe il il a beaucoup aidé on
n'est pas les seuls en effet mais cette
volontarisme et cette ambition décrété
je pense que ça peut faire écho chez des
candidats plus largement parce que
l'union européenne va mal qui a beaucoup
de choses à faire et que dire tout va
bien et on est obligé parce qu'on est
des copropriétaires de faire ce qu'on
nous demande de faire ça reste quelque
chose que les français encore une fois
peut-être les français sont des râleurs
mais n'ont pas forcément envie
d'entendre tout le temps cette question
de l'euro avait été déterminante il ya
cinq ans parce qu'il avait un flou
programmatique de marine le pen qui
avait été pointée par emmanuel macron
vous voulez sortir vous voulez pas
sortir et donc il y avait eu une valse
hésitation là il ya plus ça mais la
stratégie des manuels acron était
différente c'est de montrer que le
programme européen de marine le pen
était en trompe l'oeil se dire que sans
dire que elle veut sortir de l'europe
parce qu'elle ne peut plus le dire parce
que sa doctrine a évolué en réalité deux
facto elle en sortirait et toute sa
stratégie était de mon et que la
stratégie européenne de marine le pen
était aventureuse et je crois en effet
que l a esquissé cette alliance
européenne des nations mais sans être
suffisamment précises pour rassurer les
français sur quelque chose qui serait
faisable pragmatique et ça je trouve que
lui de ce point de vue là a été pour une
fois plus concret raphaël legendre qui
seraient les alliés si marine le pen
gagne l'élection présidentielle dimanche
de la france ça voudrait dire quoi si
c'est une forme de fric site qui dit pas
son nom il ya des pays comme la hongrie
d'organes comme la pologne des frères
kacynski qui sont sanctionnés financière
absolument c'est ça qui serait le
scénario se sont vautrés clairement les
personnels et les partenaires et les
rares partenaires que pourrait trouver
marine le pen dans cette nouvelle
construction européenne des états
nations sans quoi elle reprend le
vocabulaire de jacques delors qui avait
défini l'europe comme une europe des
états nations avec une
vision totalement différente et
effectivement quand on prend dans le
détail mesure par mesure les mesures
notamment économique de la candidat du
rassemblement national on voit qu'ils
arrivent en contravention du droit
européen à de nombreux niveaux et que
donc dès son arrivée à l'elysée son
premier déplacement serait pour
bruxelles pour venir poser un paquet sur
la table qui non seulement il est en
contravention de différentes directives
mais en expliquant en plus qu'elle
souhaiterait réduire sa participation au
pot commun c'est pas la meilleure des
bases de discussion avec les 26 oui
juste un point pour corriger sur la
pologne parce que d'ailleurs elle en
parle jamais de la pologne parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans la situation de la
guerre en ukraine la pologne est
totalement alignée sur les états unis
complètement en chine et le gouvernement
polonais même dominé par le parti droit
et justice n'a aucune envie de frayer
avec marine le pen un mot peut-être sur
la russie on va voir un sujet dans dans
un instant c'est le point d'orgue pour
vous de ceux de ce débat en termes
d'accès de la tension capter si les
manuels macro dénonce la dépendance ça a
été une belle note quand il lui a dit
quand vous parlez à la rue si vous
parlez à votre banquier c'est vrai que
c'était un peu compliqué elle a quand
même bien réagi aussi en disant oui mon
parti est pauvre et c'est pas
déshonorant mais c'est vrai que c'est
une attaque parce qu'en effet quand on
les imagine chef des armées diplomatie à
la tête de la france allait discuter
avec poutine en pleine guerre
ukrainienne qui parle d'opération
militaire spéciale c'est un peu
compliqué mais je pense que c'est aussi
significatif parce que vous rendez
compte tout ce qu'on se dit ils
attaquent ils essayent d'attaquer sur
l'union européenne sur le pouvoir
d'achat il n'a jamais réussi à
véritablement ou un tout petit peu avec
le voile à l'attaqué sur son caractère
d'extrême droite c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas été du tout sur la candidate
d'extrême droite pourtant on en a
entendu beaucoup parler dans la campagne
de l'entre-deux tours on a réentendu
l'invocation du front républicain contre
cette extrême droite d'ailleurs il
disait même plus le nom de la candidate
emmanuel macron en meeting il disait
l'extrême droite pendant ce débat je
suis désolé à partie sauf le voile on
n'a pas eu du tout l'image de la
candidate d'extrême droite qui à paris
c'est limite populistes comme vous ont
résisté judee sill aux nationalistes le
contre certains pays en europe le
deviennent mais pas du tout d'extrême
droite certains estiment de la
normalisation c'est pour wii et en plus
c'est la normalisation c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas réussi à la rodia beaulize
et comme il a essayé de le faire dans la
campagne d'entre deux tours ses
ministres aussi gabriela talent tout le
monde a essayé dit c'est la guerre sévit
c'est assez normal du bout de la
normalisation c'est à dire qu'on à
l'émergence de cette personnalité
politique purifier grâce à eric zemmour
de ces illuminés migration qui sont
toujours là mais qui sont tellement
cacher qu'on peut même pas les refaire à
paraître pendant un tel débat qui est
quand même le point d'orgue de la
campagne présidentielle soulevées sur la
guerre civile oui c'est quand même fort
ça n'a pas été non plus texto même dans
les éléments de langage qui l'a sorti
c'était impossible parce que la façon de
se présenter et de présenter son
programme ne permet plus ces attaques là
quand on est en face de cette personne
c'est vrai que ce moment de grande
tension qui est probablement le plus
tendu pour moi sur la guerre civile où
on l'a vraiment en termes lexical on est
très très au delà de ce qui s'est dit
vient aussi en fin de débat un débat
c'est très long ça a duré deux heures et
demie et je trouve pour être
parfaitement honnête que le fait d'avoir
positionner ces sujets en fin de débat
les questions d'institutions les
questions d'immigration
n'était pas neutre n'a pas joué en
faveur de marine le pen on parle de ces
questions sur lesquelles elle peut avoir
un avantage elle peut être
différenciante il est 23h30 on est animé
les gens sont déjà partis et je trouve
que c'est pas bien savoir vie sa
7e sélection des candidats avec la
négociation avec les chaînes qui
établissent l'ordre des thèmes voilà du
premier c'était un tirage au sort parce
qu'il ya les citations avec
l'international la voulait
l'international law de voulait le
pouvoir d'achat c'est le tirage au sort
qui a décidé du premier thème et je
crois
il rassemble je vais vous garder avec
moi parce que vous avez compris qu'on va
vous faire réagir affaires urgentes sur
sur la dette je vais libérer et mu a
pâti d'un bon j'ai compris à vous
entendre il a gagné ben je pense que sur
la forme il ya quand même un petit peu d
y voilà départ ce qu'on disait qu'ils
étaient un petit peu les erreurs
d'arrogance de ce président qui
candidats qui restera toujours un petit
peu comme ça à priori mais sinon oui la
gagner sur le fond il est bien plus
convaincant il est aux manettes il
maîtrise ses dossiers il était crédible
elle s'est améliorée depuis 2017 c'est
devenu une personnalité politique qui
tient coup mais son programme n'était
pas assez dans le détail et pas assez
solide même question aussi avant de vous
libérer bah oui alors on a dit olivier
on al'impression imposante en sont les
sondages
d'abord il est très rare qu'un débat est
un impact sur le scrutin il y en a eu 2
6 a eu celui de 2010 est évidemment et
ce lumineux 74 le reste chacun trouve
que son champion à gagner les sondages
montrent que l'écart s'est un peu creusé
alors je dis pas il ya eu des slogans il
y en avait un qui était suffisant alors
qu'ils étaient insuffisants c'est
peut-être un peu caricatural mais en
effet il y avait quelque chose dans
l'ethos de la crédibilité c'est très
important les taux c'est l'image qu'on
veut donner de soi et en termes d dose
de crédibilité
bah oui avait quelque chose de moins
aventureux dans ce que proposait
emmanuel macron de plus construit on
avait l'impression que chez marine le
pen ça picorer un peu et qui avait quand
même un sentiment de risque merci
infiniment merci pour la finesse de vos
analyses je vous dis à bientôt je vous
garde tous les deux roues on a compris
pourquoi un instant parce que on va
terminer ce plateau avec la place du
mensonge dans ce débat les journalistes
n'avaient pas le droit de réserve et de
relever pardonnez-moi les fakes news
hier soit seuls les candidats pouvaient
échanger sur le fond alors thibault
enoch de la rédaction d'un cpc livrer un
travail rigoureux et précieux de
vérification de toutes les affirmations
des deux finalistes hier soir regardez
est-ce que ce que j'ai dit est faux
madame le pen où il monsieur macro is
ils ont vérifié sur la russie d'abord
vous dépendez du pouvoir russe première
attaque portée par emmanuel macron vous
avez contracté un prêt en 2015 auprès
d'une banque russe la force chez crucial
banque proche du pouvoir c'est un fait
c'est faux emmanuel macron dit vrai pour
financer sa campagne des régionales en
2015 le front national a contracté un
prêt de 9 millions d'euros auprès de
cette banque russe qu'elle continue
actuellement de rembourser malgré cet
emprunt marine le pen déclare cependant
rester libre vis-à-vis de la russie et
de vladimir poutine autre sujet
directement lié l'ukraine vous avez été
je pense une des premières responsables
politiques européennes à reconnaître le
résultat de l'annexion de la crim est ce
que vous dites est faux
marine le pen a pourtant bien avalisé
cette annexion d'un territoire ukrainien
par la russie en 2014 après une
opération militaire y a pas eu d'
invasion dit d'acrimed la crimée étaient
russes dernière accusation d' emmanuel
macron concernant cette fois le conflit
actuel et l'aide à l'ukraine le cren
d'ailleurs à laquelle vous êtes aussi
opposé parlement européen l'aide
financière c'est faux emmanuel macron a
pourtant raison le 16 février dernier
les députés européens du rassemblement
national ont voté contre le prêt accordé
ce jour-là l'ukraine pour un montant d'1
virgule 2 milliards d'euros
mais emmanuel macron n'a pas été le seul
a chargé son adversaire marine le pen en
a fait de même sur un premier sujet
l'éolien en mer voulu en mettre partout
sur toutes les autres sauf en face du
touquet
ont été actés soleil en face du touquet
sur ce sujet le démenti est venue du
maire du touquet ce matin même le projet
de parc éolien faso plage de berck au
touquet a été écartée en 2010 cette
suite à une démarche du collectif
horizon que j'ai créée emmanuel macron
n'y est pour rien marine le pen a par
ailleurs fustigé les autres projets
d'éolien en mer actuellement envisagée à
50 qui sont déjà
mais seules cinq projets sont
aujourd'hui acté comme le montre cette
carte du ministère de l'écologie dernier
sujet l'économie et la dette le
président qui a créé 600 milliards
d'euros de dettes supplémentaires en
cinq ans dont deux tiers qui n'ont rien
à voir avec le candidat c'est totalement
faux adam le pet sur ce point marine le
pen a plutôt raison sur les 680
milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire durant le quinquennat
plus de la moitié n'a pas de lien avec
la crise de la cofidis
alors chose promise chose due les gens
merci d'être resté avec nous j'en
profite pour saluer stéphane blakowski
kim jalousie et mariette darrigrand
sémiologue et chroniqueuse dans cette
émission la dette 600 milliards d'euros
est la raison la marine le pen très
clairement c'est quoi le tour de
passe-passe qu'il essaye de faire passer
justement à la raison et à la raison et
pourtant les tribus jeu face à emmanuel
vacon très sûr de lui qui vous dit mais
vous n'y comprenez rien les 140
milliards qu'elle évoque durant cette
séquence sont celles des dépenses de
l'état mais il ya aussi la sécurité
sociale et les collectivités locales est
effectivement ces trois composantes fond
la dépense publique mais là où il
retourne la situation c'est qu'en
réalité il a bien son passif 600
milliards de dettes dont seulement 40 %
effectivement c'est très bien expliqué
dans une page vient en réalité de la
dette qu'ovide la dette elle n'a pas
commencé en 2020 dès 2017 nous sommes
encore à 3% de déficit en 2018 également
en 2019 les déficits continuent donc on
accumule 60 à 70 milliards d'euros de
déficit dès le début du quinquennat
chaque année alors évidemment cette
dette explose en 2020 et 2021 mais toute
la dette dès 2020 et 2050 n'est pas que
de la dette qu'ovide non plus vous avez
les dépenses courantes qui ont très
fortement augmenté aussi du fait du
quoiqu'il en elle a donc finalement il
ya des mensonges de parts et d'autres
richard vers mais plus largement même si
on voit que ofac checking c'est plutôt
emmanuel macron qui l'emportent ce qu'on
vient de voir c'est particulier c'est le
mensonge c'est quoi c'est très très
vieux en politique où ça y est la
politique c'est complètement traumatisée
en france aussi et ça va continuer bon
je crois que le mensonge le mot est
extrêmement péjoratif mais en tout cas
les affirmations les affirmations non
étayées ou non vérifiée oui c'est
fréquent politique mais je j'allais
presque dire que c'est pas très choquant
dans une campagne présidentielle
d'affirmer des choses et qui parfois
peut-être s'avèrent fausses ce qui est
plus choquant est plus problématique
c'est quand marine le pen choisie elle
d'être sur des sujets très précis donc
elle fait le choix sur les éoliennes
dette extrêmement précise et boum là il
dit une erreur donc au fond je dirais
que c'est moins grave sur la baie après
vous avez vu un il n'ya pas d'éoliennes
face au touquet mais c'est pas non mais
sauf cas d'emmanuel makrouds qu'elle dit
qu'il y en a 50 qui sont en cours alors
qu'on a vu qu'un avec seulement 5 donc
c'est là où elle fait un mauvais choix
parce que le sujet concret qu'elle
choisit et bien et bien ensemble là ça
ne va pas dans ce genre de débat il
faudrait que les vérifications soient
faites un peu en direct par les
journalistes ou c'est normal on les
laisse entre eux débattre genevois c'est
là je vois pas pourquoi il y aurait un
fact checking sur un débat télévisé
alors qu'il y en a pas pendant les
meetings électoraux très franchement
pendant les meetings électoraux les
candidats disent ce qu'ils veulent je
pense qu'il faut les laisser s'exprimer
justement le fact checking doit être un
candidat par rapport à l'autre c'est
sale débat démocratique et puis dernière
question est il normal que ont choisi ce
un peu les journalistes ont négocié aux
marchands de même un peu les règles du
jeu quelques jours avant le le débat
avec les équipes de campagne aux etats
unis c'est pas comme ça que ça a
toujours été le cas en tout cas en
france mais on voit bien qu'on arrive un
peu au bout d'un modèle un peu
poussiéreux un débat de deux heures
cinquante qui est beaucoup trop long il
faudrait le coupé en deux en réalité
pour éviter la fatigue aussi un des deux
candidats autour de la table la fatigue
ou aussi des électeurs des
téléspectateurs parce que les
journalistes soient choisis à venir
alors là on a craint que deux candidats
les journalistes sont souvent un peu ton
chat se mettre en avant en fait il
voudrait en fait un peut être les
vedettes de la soirée ils sont
totalement absents dans cet exercice par
exemple
mais sa qualité d'interviews c'est
qu'elle interrompt souvent qu'elle tient
tête aux gens que le sommet un petit peu
en vedette donc pendant débat comme ça
autant écouter
extrêmement normes et ce genre de débat
on l'a vu hier d'ailleurs avec serge
moati et à vingt-et-une règle
pas ils pensent ou téléspectateur il
vient d'inventer l'entracte
présidentielle à l'elite de blacko a
évidemment oro on reste dans le schéma
de nos de nos émissions habituelles
l'oeil de blackhawk art oratoire
carte blanche sur les réactions à ce
débat qu'est ce qu'elle vous on espère
écoutez ça me fait un peu de mal de vous
l'avouer elle vous tous sont notamment à
vomir yens j'ai peur de vous décevoir
mais je suis absolument comme tout le
monde
j'ai été frappé par l'attitude de macron
bon voilà sauf que moi je suis dans la
catégorie de gens que ça a plutôt fait
marrer le gars à qui on dit mais mille
fois avant le débat et surtout emmanuel
surtout la priorité ne soit pas arrogant
bîmes il s'assoit et d'emblée on sent
que vraiment ils la calcule même pas
sûrs j'ai passé la soirée avec cette
meuf mais qu'est ce que je vais lui dire
donc maman j'ai trouvé ça assez
réjouissant cet aplomb cette audace papa
vous bah disons que ça n'avait pas l'air
tout le monde en tout cas oui alors
c'est vrai que ça ne fait pas rire tout
le monde mais on ne peut pas rire de
tout avec tout le monde vous le savez
donc il ya quand même des gens que ça
amuse et jeu des prix un tweak à naples
un mot cela m'a fait marrer wac qui les
vaincront avait un peu l'air tenue
médecin traitant qui on a cherché à
embrouiller un petit peu sur le thème
oui je suis peut-être maladroit il avait
un peu c'est cette allure vous
reconnaissez un mais ça n'a pas fait
rire tout le monde par exemple louis
aliot lui il n'a pas du tout rigoler 1
ça c'est du mépris et sa caractérise
l'attitude de bach rond sur le fond les
réactions alors au risque de paraître à
mon tour arrogant je vais citer victor
hugo bon alors rassurez vous j'ai
regardé sur internet après midi pas
comme si j'étais cultivé mais il a dit
c'est le fond qui remonte à la sur la
forme c'est le fond qui remonte à la
surface donc effectivement si macron
apparu de regarder marine le pen de haut
c'est sans doute qu'au fond de lui même
il la méprise effectivement un peu il la
regarde effectivement un peu de ça s'est
vu un peu gros comme une maison ripoliné
pas mon ami mais gabriel attaques de
leurs ce matin il a pas nié il a pas dit
mâcon épargants il a juste dit attention
il ya une vraie différence entre le fond
et la forme j'ai entendu les
responsables du rassemblement national
se concentrer essentiellement sur le
sujet de la forme après un échange de
près de trois heures sur tous les sujets
de fond que le principal sujet dont il
parle c'est la question de la forme ça
montre bien qu'ils ne sont pas très à
l'aise pour commenter le fond 1 qu'est
ce qu'il est brillant saga brilinta dont
on se demande quel poste il aura dans le
prochain gouvernement pas si vous avez
des infos c'est le moment de se murmure
déjà parce que parmi ceux qui ont voulu
aider macron y avait aussi jean pierre
raffarin plein de bonne volonté qui
vient ce matin sur lci expliquer
pourquoi macro apparu un peu arrogant
c'est protéger moi de mes amis mes
ennemis je m'en charge parce que là ça
du coup de couteau dans le dos et
pourtant il croyait bien faire on écoute
quand vous regardez quelqu'un en faisant
vous êtes concentré et puis après vous
allez vous reposer pour aller regarder
ailleurs pour vous détendre pour
reprendre un peu de soi alors là si vous
pouvez avoir un peu de relâchement et
l'ati la caméra passe naturellement vous
donner un sentiment ou de vous endormir
ou au contraire d'être trop agressif
donc c'est très dangereux en effet de ce
type d'attitude donc croyez sans un bon
gros vieux politiciens de l'ancienne
école non mais ne riez pas c'est très
important quand on se présente à une
élection on ne doit jamais mépriser les
électeurs en tout cas jamais donné
l'impression qu'on les méprise gris si
les insoumis alors on a pensé du débat
avec seconde question parce que
maintenant que jean luc mélenchon a
perdu je le répète c'est officiel jean
luc mélenchon a perdu donc maintenant
qu'il a perdu on se dit bah alors ils
vont préférer qui maquereau ou le pen la
réponse de corbières qui est sorti
gagnant hier soir je vais dire jean luc
mélenchon
je dirais bien sûr c'est un point de vue
très comme les millions de gens qui se
sont regroupés derrière notre
candidature mais quelle absence
s'assoyait je puis dire bon on avait à
la fois un président
dans toute son arrogance social qui n'a
jamais été contesté finalement
réellement et sérieusement par marine le
pen je ne comprends pas pour quelle
raison elle était aussi molle mais tout
le monde est de bonne humeur après ce
débat marine le pen a été trois mâles et
bien sûr que jean luc mélenchon lui
aurait tenu tête à macron va penser
alors finalement à part le rassemblement
national tout le monde pense que c'est
macron qu'il a gagné ce n'est pas moi
j'ai un petit doute d'ailleurs j'ai un
petit doute parce que oui sur il a gagné
aux points mais il l'a pas mis marine le
pen
k o parce qu'elle s'en est plutôt bien
tiré son cas là explique ray assis
calmement la colère que peuvent
ressentir les classes populaires sans
jamais hausser le ton sans se comporter
comme un gilet jaune mais ça a été dit
et entendu je pense alors bien sûr on
regarde le sondage 59 % des français ont
trouvé macron plus convaincant ouais
mais il ya quand même des points sur
lequel marine le pen elle était beaucoup
plus convaincante en écoute bernard
sananès c'est lui qui a fait sondages
marine le pen en revanche l'emportent
très nettement sur la capacité à changer
les choses et ça c'est très important à
quelques jours d'une élection notamment
pour elle qui veut agréger les colères
qui veut agréger le mécontentement de
tous ceux qui ne sont pas satisfaits de
la situation de la situation actuelle
donc voilà ma petite conclusion on a
donc un référendum pour savoir dimension
veux que ça continue ou si on veut que
ça change et on verra si les français
veulent en majorité que ça continue ou
que ça change
le choix des français alors mariette ce
soir le regard de la sémiologue nous dit
au fond que ce débat était finalement
très technique on n'a pas eu beaucoup
d'imaginaire dans ce débat hier aucune
envolée lyrique pas vraiment d'émotion
pas de métaphore à de belles métaphores
qui aurait pu mettre un peu d'oxygène ou
même de cinéma dans l'air voilà un mois
j'attendis les métaphores je les chasse
un jeu les guette et je les prends dans
mon épouse est sémiologie quand elle
arrive il y en a eu deux pas beaucoup
assure trois heures de temps il y en a
eu 2 puis elle était en plus très petit
trait minuscule la première c'est marine
enfin c'est pas la première
chronologiquement mais celle de marine
le pen à la toute fin elle a dit je veux
recoudre le pays et c'est une soirée
plus est une métaphore intéressante
qu'elle aurait pu prendre dès le début
le tisserand c'est chez platon déjà donc
y avait quelque chose de potentiellement
intéressant là dedans on s'est passé
très vite on était plutôt dans les
travaux de couture et 2e métaphore là on
l'a vu tout à l'heure encore chez
emmanuel macron cette fois c'est la
fameuse réunion de copropriété oui voilà
donc ça c'est une métaphore très
concrète prosaïque et donc dans les deux
cas elle a été très pédagogique je crois
oui une fois on dit on va aussi sur ce
blabla la voilà mais dans les deux cas
je dirais que ce sont des métaphores
domestiques qui ne nous amène pas dans
le travelling sinon je reprends votre
métaphore en tout cas voilà ça fait pas
rêver on était vraiment dans le close up
très loin de chaos parce qu'elle est on
a parlé du cas où c'est une hyperbole
même fut durant la campagne là
l'argument moi du tout le mot n'est pas
sortie elle n'a pas été en colère et
emmanuel macron bella on était très loin
du son optimisme de la start up nation
alors vous nous dites que ce
rétrécissement à la fois avec des
langages enfin dans les dents les
argumentations mérite qu'on s'y arrête
pourtant la société s'est enthousiasmé
ces dernières années pour les grandes
métaphore ben oui c'est ça qui est
intéressant je crois pour les
observateurs c'est que en quelque sorte
la société montre qu'elle a besoin
d'imagés qu'elles sont tous dias nous
pour des images collectif c'est pour ça
que c'est intéressant en démocratie les
métaphores ça fait quelque chose de
collectif on n'est pas obligé tous
d'adhérer au même mais ça nous fait
quelque chose sur sur lequel se projeter
alors je vais en prendre deux dans la
société actuelle on en a parlé c'est par
exemple la représentation de la nature
qui n'intéressaient personne l'écologie
quand c'était la protection de
l'environnement donc un réel quand c'est
devenu mère nature sur laquelle on est
quasiment dans un rapport religieux
certains parlent de ghayath une sorte de
sainte vierge enfin on peut vraiment là
aujourd'hui voir qu'il ya des excès bien
sûr mais c'est pas grave on a quelque
chose qui entraîne et puis dans un
registre différent mais ça touche aussi
de politique je pense est la métaphore
de la vie comme un voyage chacun nous
voit sa vie comme un voyage vous avez
reçue il ya quelques temps boris
cyrulnik il n'explique bien ça c'est
encore une métaphore vivent quand il
parle des épreuves et des résilience bah
ça on n'a pas vu dans le dans la
campagne du tout vent général et dans le
débat d'hier soir merci beaucoup alors
il nous aurions proposé un voyage chacun
et les
organes de fort formidable de la
convalescence parce que nous sommes dans
un moment posco vide et dans chacun
d'eux pouvait la prendre à sa façon
marie ne pas ne pouvait dire bas la
france souffre mais elle va aller mieux
et c'est une comédie sens un peu
médicale et puis macron pouvait la
prendre sur un plan beaucoup plus
optimiste est symbolique et je
terminerai là dessus parce que pour moi
c'est un petit bijou cette convalescence
way dont les américains parlent plus 5
parle souvent de convalescence
économique par exemple
l'étymologie c'est comme vale ray ça
veut dire être valeureux ensemble chacun
de nous dans son corps avec ses organes
qui vont comme tout enfant il y en a un
qui va pas mettre l'ensemble se dégrade
et puis surtout tous ensemble dans ce
corps social quel toute société
beaucoup ça vous inspire
l'analyse des métaphores et en disent
long moi ce qui m'a frappé dans le dans
le débat une chose qui m'a frappé c'est
quand elle est allée chercher quelque
chose qui lui tient à coeur c'est le la
vie animale le droit animal marine le
pen est là elle aurait pu tenter quelque
chose elle est là et là on sent qu'elle
a voulu vraiment d'abord touché une
partie de son public mais aussi montrer
qu'elle est une candidate de la
compassion ce qui alors pour le coup est
à l'opposé l'image qu'on a l'habitude
mais ça n'a pas vraiment marché me
semble-t-il merci à vous en tout cas
merci beaucoup pour ce grand tour
d'horizon très complet ce décryptage
dans tout secteur de ce débat d'entre
deux tours on va à présent accueillir
notre grand témoin il a consacré toute
sa vie ou presque à l'europe ancien
commissaire européen il coordonne
aujourd'hui les instituts jacques delors
de paris bruxelles et berlin il préside
le forum sur la paix cette paix qui
devait garantir l'europe balayé
aujourd'hui par la guerre en ukraine on
a plein de questions à poser à pascal
lamy qui nous rejoint dans un instant
comme les skis ce sujet de marco pommier
si on vous invite pascal lamy c'est
parce que vous êtes un grand observateur
des tendances mondiales avec vous nous
voulons parler de guerre et de paix face
à l'atrocité des violences en ukraine
qui ne laisse personne indifférent vous
le premier
beaucoup de tristesse pour ma génération
seule la prière c'est un retour
effroyable
sur le passé votre cv pascal lamy a de
quoi impressionner
ancien directeur de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce mais aussi ex
commissaires européens à la méthode de
négociation
implacable chacun sa manière de négocier
chacun a ses méthodes moi je le fais
plutôt de manière car est calme et
confiant tain je peux me fâcher le cas
échéant s'il faut aujourd'hui vous êtes
à la tête du forum de paris sur la paix
forum sur les questions de gouvernance
et de multilatéralisme tout dans votre
parcours vos livres vous ramène à
l'europe dont vous n'avez cessé de
défendre les intérêts cette europe
effrayer ces dernières semaines par
l'escaladé souffrance en ukraine pour
nous européens c'est aussi une épreuve
redoutable et déterminante dont nous
sortirons soient plus forts soient
renforcées soit affaiblie alors pascal
lamy à l'heure où les victimes civiles
se comptent par milliers où les réfugiés
franchissent les portes de lieux par
millions à l'euro l'offensive russe
s'intensifie dans le donbass et alors
que vladimir poutine vient de
revendiquer la prise de mario paul ville
assiégée et détruite plusieurs questions
ce soir l'europe doit-elle en faire plus
redoutez-vous
une extension du conflit et faut-il
traiter vladimir poutine de criminels de
guerre nous attendons vos réponses
bonsoir pascal lamy ravi de vous
recevoir sur ce plateau garantir la paix
c'est la mission historique de l'europe
et pourtant la guerre est au coeur de
l'europe est elle s'intensifie en
ukraine bien évidemment avec cette
offensive dans le don base est-ce que
vous l'européen vous diriez d'abord que
cette guerre c'est notre guerre
oui et non oui parce que ça se passe sur
le sol européen
et que même si l'ukraine n'est pas un
pays membre de l'union européenne en
tout cas pas pour l'instant il vous
savez que c'est une question qui est
ouverte
ça se passe quand même tout près tout
près de chez nous alors nous français
pas vraiment enfin les pays baltes sont
la frontière de la biélorussie russie il
ya des pays comme la pologne la roumanie
qui sont dans le secteur est donc pour
ces pays là qui appartiennent à la même
union que nous c'est un choc absolument
considérable parce que ça se passe à
l'heure d'hiver aussi contre les valeurs
même de l'europe alors là démarre
ailleurs par ailleurs c'est une guerre
que monsieur poutine a initié pour des
raisons qui tiennent à sa phobie de
l'eau thann
et elle est accompagnée en train d'un
double narratif comme on dit en gros et
10 l'ukraine c'est à nous
l'histoire
nous a donné une graine pour des raisons
de circonstance elle nous a échappée
prend un moment m'enfin maintenant il
est temps que je me dépêche de l'afp et
puis par ailleurs vous avez raison il ya
un autre narratif qui est que essaye de
le développe depuis maintenant une
dizaine d'années moi je les rencontre et
un pour négocier
l'entente la russie en 2004 et on était
déjà là affaire à quelqu'un qui
était d'accord avec la proposition
européenne de l'époque de faire une zone
de libre échange entre la russie et
l'union européenne l'idée étant qu'au
fond on est un peu dans le même lit
géoéconomique qu'effectivement ils ont
beaucoup d'énergie une économie pas très
sophistiqué nous on a des économies très
sophistiqué pas beaucoup d'énergie tout
ça alors j'aimerais vous entendre sur au
fond notre rôle et notre mission est ce
que vous trouvez vraiment que l'europe
est à la hauteur au fond on a sanctionné
économiquement et financièrement la
russie on arme les ukrainiens et on
tente de parler à poutine enfin après
bout de chat je crois que la ligne est
un peu est un pont interrompue rien ne
l'arrête pourtant le maître du kremlin
rien ne l'arrête et là c'est encore pire
après après les massacres après le viol
des femmes on voit ce qui se passe dans
le donbass à mario paul dont il dit qui
il est villé est prise il a ses mots
lusine vous savez à azov salle on
résiste les derniers les derniers
soldats de l'armée ukrainienne est dit
il faut faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
une seule mouche qui ne passait ce que
nous sommes véritablement à la hauteur
de nos valeurs au rendez vous de
l'histoire nous européens face à cela
l'europe et lo tan
parce qu'en l'occurrence
militairement l'europe c'est l'automne à
il faut reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui
adam erne et herman l'europe c'est le
tan dans ce genre de circonstances donc
l'europe et le tan aide les ukrainiens
lui fournissent des moyens militaires
ce qui est un geste sans aucun précédent
dans l'histoire de l'union européenne
depuis qu'on a commencé le marché commun
dans les années sombres en moins quand
même que les britanniques un peu moins
bons américains
nous nous fournissons des armements
l'étau pas seulement des gilets
pare-balles ont fourni des
lance-roquettes des roquettes anti chars
des roquettes antiaériennes
on fait ce que les circonstances
géopolitique d'aujourd'hui nous
permettent de faire
à l'intérieur d'une ligne rouge des deux
côtés qui est celle de la dissuasion
nucléaire je crois que
je comprends très bien votre question
parce que beaucoup de gens qui dit mais
pourquoi finalement on va pas leur
rentrer dans le chou on ne va pas nous
rentrer dans le chou des russes parce
que les russes sont une puissance
nucléaire
et nous savons que les russes nous ne
rentrerons pas dans le chou à nous parce
que nous sommes une puissance nucléaire
justement si la dissuasion même si c'est
un état nucléaire fonctionne oui
pourquoi pourquoi dans ces cas là ne pas
se passer du gaz russe et est beaucoup
plus dissuasif et fort dans les
sanctions les pays baltes selon même pas
forcément nous venons mais la france
pour un mur et nous nous y venons nous y
venons vous avez raison on appris des
champions encore une fois d'une ampleur
sans aucun précédente et qui font très
mal à l'économie russe est de mon point
de vue et je les dis en toute
indépendance
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines je
pense que l'union européenne doit aller
jusqu'à se priver des importations de
charbon on a commencé de pétrole
l'allemand s'est pour le moment tuyaux
si je puis dire et du gan
même si ceci implique des efforts de
notre part mais ça on ne peut pas le
faire la france ou l'espagne ou l'italie
les pays-bas l'ont fait seul alors
qu'elles sont plus dépendants canon paix
badelon fait seul tout en étant branché
sur une grille énergétique qui est la
grille européenne donkey escale à
fournir de l'énergie aux pays baltes
quand ils ne vont pas en produire assez
ce sont les autres européens donc là on
ne peut on ne peut travailler quand
européen je pense que c'est ce qu'il
faut faire je comprends que nos amis
allemands qui sont beaucoup plus exposés
que nous à l'absence d'un gaz russe dont
ils ont besoin je comprends que ça
prenne un peu de temps je pense qu'on y
va et si monsieur poutine continue et
pour l'instant ils continuent alors nous
devons continuer on doit en quelque
sorte qu'il est proportionné nos
sanctions
ses propres aux agressions des
conséquences économiques de la guerre en
europe sur nous les européens
l'inflation et à plus de 4% en france a
fait pour cent en allemagne jusqu'où ça
peut aller
ils ont ils nous avons une inflation qui
est
de 3 origins il y en avait une dans le
tuyau avant l'invasion de l'ukraine par
la russie à la suite du coc vide
parce que les l'économie européenne
comme d'ailleurs la plupart des
économies ont assez fortement rebondi
après les confinements et l'offre n'a
pas suivi la demande est monté l'offre
n'a pas suivi quesqu'il pas dans ce cas
là
ensuite on a effectivement les
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
c'est à dire un renchérissement du prix
d'énergie parce que les spéculateurs sur
les marchés de l'énergie se disent que
ça va se terminer et que par ailleurs
l'opep qui contrôle le robinet en
profite pour empêcher pour empocher des
prix très très haut j'ai toujours trouvé
que cette acceptation par ce qu'on
appelle le capitalisme de marché d'un
cartel d'un cartel d'une entente dans
tout dans tous nos états dans tous nos
pays on lutte contre le cartel et les un
temps là on a des gens qui pour des
raisons historiques ont la main sur le
robinet est évidemment il empoche la
différence et puis on a par ailleurs
elle début d'inflation dans le secteur
alimentaire même si je vois pas madame
irma mais ça peut durer combien de temps
cette hausse des prix cette flambée des
prix je pense que dans l'année qui vient
nous allons aller vers les s'est uni
pour cent et que ensuite ensuite ça
redescendra c'est d'ailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs ce que pense aussi le fmi la
banque mondiale ocde donc toutes les
grandes organisations de bonheur le
risque de la spirale inflationniste
les prix montent des salaires montent et
la croissance et basse ça s'appelle la
station si je dis pas de bêtises est ce
que ça existe c'est ce que ça nous
guette comme à mon époque je ne crois
pas que ça nous guette mais mais
croire que pour un certain nombre de
raisons
l'économie mondiale de cette année et de
l'année prochaine ne sera pas là où nous
pensions tous que d'été à la fin d'année
dernière à dire précisément concrètement
pour ceux qui n'auront on était sûr qu
on était sûrs du 3 5 4% à tracer en
croissance de l'économie mondiale on est
maintenant plutôt sur du 3 3 2 on a
perdu en gros 0,7 point de croissance et
ça c'est pas une bonne nouvelle parce
que il ya des choses là dedans qui vont
durer regardez ce qui se passe en chine
et qui pèsent sur cette absence de
croissance mondiale des chinois n'arrive
pas à se sortir du confinement ils dans
leur politique de zéro comme il ne
marche pas ils sont obligés de retirer
leurs économies et quand la chine a un
problème le monde a un problème
peut-être on verra ça peut jouer un rôle
même si pour l'instant elle est assez
neutre dans ce compte peut être un mot
très rapides puisque le temps presse et
ça s'arrête l'europe c'est toujours
construits dans des crises après la
guerre en ukraine vous la voyez
renforcer ou affaiblis
très rapidement je je je n'en sais rien
je pense qu'elle sortira et je vais déjà
dit soit renforcée soit affaiblie je
crois qu'elle sortira renforcée mais ça
dépendra vraiment des conditions de
sortie de cette crise on en est loin je
crois néanmoins que dans la population
européenne
l'idée que nous pouvons être nous mêmes
victimes d'agressions
même si nous disposons du parapluie
nucléaire va faire progresser dans
l'opinion l'idée qu'il faut davantage
d'europe de la défense ce message la
campagne présidentielle merci infiniment
pascal lamy on vous invitera
écourtée malheureusement c'est la fin de
cette émission on se retrouve demain
pour un nouveau ça vous regarde pour la
voir ou à revoir ya la chaîne youtube de
lcp tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire ce soir un documentaire
inédit il faut ramener albert un film
sur la transmission des mémoire de la
guerre d'algérie très belle soirée à
demain
[Musique]